maybe toss an egg in there for me that
actually would be pretty good okay good
bath you on me like I'm a very fancy
person what's up guys I'm ANCA I grew up
in Hong Kong and I love instant ramen I
know most people think instant ramen is
more like a broke college students
breakfast lunch and dinner but come on
guys there are so many more amazing
instrument brands out there that people
need to try so I went to Chinatown found
a couple of my favorite brands brought
them back to the office to show my
co-workers a whole new world
[Music]
this looks legit and it smells really
good Mel's legit oh that's chin smell
it's reminiscent of instant ramen but
but better it's a little spicier than I
was expecting which is a pleasant
surprise lots of flavor
no salty spicy spicy the broth really
tastes like the broth you get at the
restaurant when you go get foxy ramen
I'm like probably gonna finish this
that's okay I'm excited for the next one
yeah
[Music]
on this yeah it looks fancier than the
one that we just had smells almost like
creamier maybe is it uni truffle powder
little I'm trying so hard to place it
I feel like there's coconut in this
definitely something from the ocean is
in here it's the perfect amount of like
salty yeah
spicy and creamy I like milk but only in
coffee or cereal so not necessarily when
it's mixed in with other stuff I'm
surprised this is instant this is my new
favorite this one looks like artisanal
it smells incredible it really knows
expensive it is so beautiful we got
wrong yeah no bra I've never had no on
noodles before though YUM
yes good the flavors are really crazy
and like kind of baked into them noodles
the Mayo is so interesting I don't know
if I would have picked it but like now
that I'm eating it I'm like into it I
would never assume it came from like a
dried form I'm like super into this just
tastes really good to me this is very
pretty restaurant Raleigh this tastes
like restaurant quality it's like a
rainy day and I'm in my PJs yeah a bike
I would snack on them yeah clearly yeah
it's only good yeah
really clean I thought I knew all kinds
of mr. AMA but today my mind is blown
because there were some different
flavors not only it's like the quality
can be better but also like there's so
much of different types and
interpretation they're pretty cool they
really defied my expectations in terms
of what the form a landscape was like
I've seen the other side I cannot go
back like you're gonna journey yeah we
traveled your change man yeah today
changed me that flavor and the water as
well I mean the broth as well sorry
water
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]